>> Hi, everybody.
With the rapid increase of, uh, population
and typical growth, waste
is becoming a serious problem, a major concern
for most of the urban
areas in developing countries.
Today, [inaudible], municipalities, and local
bodies, with their
limited resources, simply cannot handle this
huge amount of waste and,
uh, a major portion of this waste, almost
50 percent, remains
uncollected in the roads, drains, and low-lying
area and it is
creating new health environmental problems
in the city as well as
creating greenhouse gas and also it is creating
-- causing diseases in
the city.
So I present most of the cities are focusing
-- municipal city --
municipal bodies and cities are focusing on
end of the par solution
which is focused on collection, transportation,
and crude dumping and
they're not solving the problem.
What we should do: I am a social entrepreneur,
I am from Bangladesh,
I think if you look at this as a problem it
is very expensive to solve
but we are saying that waste is not a problem,
it's a resource and if
you look at waste as a resource you can solve
this problem.
We cannot look at waste as a problem, a developed
country like us.
So in Wisconsin we developed a model where
we can recycle all work --
a huge amount of organic waste -- almost 80
percent in the west
developing country -- we can convert it into
fertilizer compost as
well as we can harness the carbon trading.
It's a new parallel and, uh, almost the -- we
can harness investment
from developed country to developing country.
So the model we have developed we can, uh,
use collective waste in
partnership with the community and also recycle
it with Arabic
technology which reduces -- which does not
create any greenhouse gas
and, uh, it can then -- with this kind of
technology you can help
more municipalities with finance, technology,
and we can, uh, have
partnership -- improve the partnership because
right now in developing
country there is no partnership between the
municipal government and
the people.
So in this project we are trying -- we are
improving the partnership
between the people, beneficially, and the
cities as well and we think
that this kind of, uh, project can improve
the situation dramatically.
Right now we're working in 26 cities -- Bangladesh
and this idea is
being implicated in Sri Lanka, in Vietnam,
and very soon Pakistan and
Egypt people are training to [unintelligible]
this model.
So I think I believe in 2008 to all the developing
countries -- to all
cities of the developing world can harness
this carbon financing using
our model and if they can use this kind of
model in their city it can
improve their situation and we can reach the
minimum development goal.
Thank you.